[موسيقى]
الناس هنا بتعصر زيت الزيتون وبتوفر
الزيتون وصعب الطرق بتوفره لتقدر تجيبه
هون وبتوفر الس باصعب الطرق لتقدر تعصر
الزيتون هان كان في اطفال بشكل كبير
بالشارع كان في عندك جيران استشهد عدد
كبير وكان في عننا ما يقارب 150 اصابه في
المكان ما كنا ملحقين عدد اصابات لموا
الزيتون عشان ي يعصرو وياكلو من زيته
والناس خرب عليهم كل حاجه يعني هي دمر
المعصره والزيتون كب في الشارع والزيت كب
في الشارع وبهدل العالمم ح نرحل من فلسطين
مش ح نرحل من غزه ولا متحركين لو بنموت كل
هيتنا ايش نسوي لهم احنا بنطلب من ربنا
العالمين ما بنطلب من العالم العالم ومو
شافونا وبيشوفوا كل يوم وبيسوا كل حاجه
وبيسمعنا واحنا بنصي وبنقول نا وبجي ربنا
احنا بناجي رب العالمين بجيش العالم
العالم لودهم فينا كان زمان وقفوا على
الحدود وقفوا كل حاجه
ا